[Musica]
[Applauso]
essere sottoposto al giudizio di chi mi
osserva quindi in questo caso voi mi
crea sempre un certo nervosismo
disagio agitazione però dall'altra parte
anche una sfida con me stesso perché
vorrei riuscire a superare questi limiti
mentali
quest'anno celebra 25 anni di carriera
da presentatore professionista però
essendo fondamentalmente un timido per
me il palco rimane sempre come un ring è
una specie di arena
devo riuscire a combattere contro tutte
le mie insicurezze una volta però non
era così ero molto più tranquillo
sciolto disinvolto riuscivo a ottenere i
miei obiettivi con grande facilità avevo
il lavoro dei miei sogni
radiotelevisione successo fama soldi
direi che me la spassavo alla grande
però
l'esposizione alle prime critiche ha
cominciato a tirar fuori tutte le mie
fragilità
le parole avvelenate hanno cominciato a
farmi male perché perché io mi ponevo di
fronte al pubblico senza scudi senza
armature quindi ogni parola riusciva a
centrare il bersaglio
ferendomi facendomi male ho cominciato a
perdere le mie sicurezze le mie
convinzioni
ho iniziato ad avere paura del giudizio
degli altri e quindi piano piano sono
sprofondato in uno stato di depressione
perché oltre ai successi sono arrivati
anche i fallimenti e sebbene io
continuassi a risalire
ero sempre vulnerabile e fragile e così
depressione depressione come ne soffre
tanta gente ho raccontato questo periodo
in televisione e da quel momento la
gente ha cominciato a chiedermi di
condividere questa storia così ho
scritto un libro la faccia nascosta
della luce in cui descrive
dettagliatamente come ne sono uscito da
questo periodo e a giudicare dal numero
di messaggi che ho ricevuto dagli
incontri nelle librerie ho capito che di
depressione ne soffre molta più gente di
quanto immaginassi
prima di riuscire a uscirne però
attraversato tempeste interiori emotive
sono caduto tante volte mi sono fatto
male ho ceduto alle debolezze e sono
caduto in uno stato di prostrazione
totale la caduta non è avvenuta
all'improvviso è stato un lento
scivolare tra le pieghe dell'anima negli
anni
cercando di investigare i miei mondi
interiori mi sono perso proprio nei
meandri della coscienza era sempre
stanco apatico ero come avvolto da da
questo involucro appiccicoso come una
ragnatela che mi isolava dal resto del
mondo fuori c'era il sole che splendeva
per me era come se non esistesse
avevo una famiglia che mi amava non
riuscivo a capirlo lavoravo sì certo
però siccome sapevo di stare male allora
avevo paura che anche gli altri se ne
accorgessero quindi io schiavo mi
nascondevo poi arrivavo a casa ero
stravolto ma non riuscivo a dormire
in quel periodo avevo delle abitudini
malsane andavo a letto ogni notte alle
prime luci dell'alba ma era così tutti i
giorni settimane mesi anni
per questo a ne lavo l'oblio
volevo farmi
bevendo come una spugna non ho fatto
altro che peggiorare le cose
il mio aspetto esteriore era lo specchio
dei miei pensieri auto distruttivi
emanava proprio un energia sporca
ero così chiuso il mio guscio al riparo
nella mia tana e una alla volta ho
staccato tutte le connessioni con il
mondo esterno
mi sono ritrovato completamente solo ad
affrontare il lato più buio della mia
coscienza in perenne stato di
alterazione
una situazione veramente molto
pericolosa se avessi continuato così
avrei perso tutto la famiglia il lavoro
la vita
è stata la paura risvegliarmi
all'improvviso lo spavento di essere
arrivato al punto oltre al quale la
morte non era più un idea ma una
possibilità
una paura così grande d'avermi fattori
aggrappare immediatamente alla vita con
tutto me stesso
sto parlando di una paura di quel genere
che ti fa diventare la barba ei capelli
bianchi vi racconto una notte
ho sfiorato la fine
mi sono guardato allo specchio
ed era come se un barlume dal fondo
degli occhi
proiettasse questo urlo e per la prima
volta riuscivo a percepirne l'eco cazzo
stai facendo
mi sono sciacquato ero sconvolto tremo
ancora se ci penso però
respiravo ho capito che ero ancora vivo
eccoli è avvenuto il risveglio da solo
avevo deciso di salvarmi
piano piano ho raccolto le schegge di
luce
ho cercato di ricomporre quei momenti di
felicità che avevo infranto ho cercato
di ricordarmi tutti i momenti belli più
emozionanti quei picchi di gioia che
sapevo di aver vissuto e che mi facevano
stare subito bene
così
piano piano cercato di protrarre questi
momenti il più possibile la risalita è
stata fortunatamente più veloce rispetto
alla caduta
perché perché gli effetti sono immediati
quindi avevo proprio voglia di ripulirmi
mentalmente fisicamente quindi ho smesso
di bere
ho iniziato a mangiare meglio ho ripreso
ad allenarmi a quel punto volevo anche
uscire dal mio guscio quindi finalmente
ho accettato l'aiuto di tutti quelle
persone che mi avevano teso la mano e
che io avevo rifiutato quindi la
famiglia gli amici lo psicologo è stato
fondamentale
ora riesco a gestire un pochino meglio
le mie emozioni
quando sento i primi segnali di
cedimento
la voce si fa sentire e mi dice e lì non
ci vuoi tornare giusto
ecco quindi quando ho paura quando ansia
angoscia per qualsiasi cosa cosa faccio
mi fermo
prendo un bel respiro
e poi utilizzo tutte quelle tecniche
mentali che mi riportano negli stati di
quiete da cui immediatamente ritrovo la
giusta prospettiva
ecco è molto importante coltivare la
propria mente come un giardino è i
pensieri negativi sono le erbacce che lo
infestano se noi lo trascuriamo noi
siamo i giardinieri dei nostri pensieri
peccato che a scuola non si abbiano
insegnato come gestire poi questi
pensieri questo turbinio di agitazioni
che proviamo sin dalla più tenera età
il nostro mondo interiore fatto di
emozioni sentimenti fantasie
immaginazioni che poi anche un aspetto
determinante della nostra vita i
pensieri possiedono una forza reale
è difficile da ammettere però noi in
ogni frazione di secondo decidiamo chi
essere quindi se proiettiamo luce
vedremo soprattutto le cose belle
semanya mo sentimenti negativi ci
troveremo in quello stato di realtà la
realtà è quella che ci creiamo noi noi
siamo la nostra proiezione mentale e non
importa quante difficoltà dobbiamo
affrontare possono essere avversità
fisiche psichiche
sentimentali economiche se abbiamo la
facoltà di pensare allora possiamo
focalizzare la nostra forza di volontà
per visualizzare la soluzione più
luminosa e quindi creare una nuova
realtà
la visualizzazione è proprio l'uso della
fantasia allo scopo di immaginare una
situazione non ancora reale per
realizzare i nostri desideri
praticamente consiste nel crearsi
un'immagine mentale di quello che
desideriamo e coltivarla con costanza
giorno dopo giorno dopo giorno
il discorso però è legato cioè il
segreto di questa tecnica alla
sensazione che proviamo cioè noi più
riusciamo a metterci dentro dei dettagli
in questa immagine e meglio sarà
è una tecnica che utilizza
ancora perché così riesco a tracciare la
mia rotta cosa faccio mi immagino in
diverse situazioni e provo a sentire le
sensazioni che provano che sento quindi
per esempio mentre coltivo la terra o
sono a lavorare appunto in un terreno
così agricoltura oppure mi immagino
mentre sto cantando davanti a un
pubblico se una di queste ipotesi mi
suscita qualcosa di bello quindi tipo le
farfalle allo stomaco
allora cosa faccio mi soffermo inizio a
inserire tutti i dettagli ea costruire
questa scena cercando di capire perché
mi faccia sentire così bene è così a
quel punto l'entusiasmo che provo
accende la forza di volontà che mette in
moto tutte quelle dinamiche che servono
per raggiungere il proprio obiettivo
il primo passaggio è quello di
circondarsi di persone che orbitano
attorno al mondo dei nostri interessi in
modo da creare dei link delle
connessioni delle sinergie che aumentino
la probabilità di successo è molto
facile da capire la differenza sta nel
metterla in pratica
inserire questa tecnica nella vita di
tutti i giorni è
fondamentale per riuscire a ottenere i
propri obiettivi i propri sogni
l'ho imparato dalla mia guida spirituale
franco battiato
se vuoi conoscere i tuoi pensieri di
ieri osserva il tuo corpo oggi se vuoi
sapere come sarai domani osserva i tuoi
pensieri oggi
battiato mi ha indicato tutte le
tecniche di meditazione che uso
quotidianamente mi ha anche fornito gli
strumenti necessari per superare le
crisi esistenziali e poi mi ha insegnato
a dialogare con il mio sé più profondo
oltre i rumori dei pensieri coscienti
quel chiacchiericcio che sentiamo sempre
nella mente no ho fatto di
preoccupazioni incombenze reazioni agli
stimoli esterni
esiste la vastità del subconscio da cui
emerge la voce del vero se connesso con
il tutto
qui entriamo nella sfera dell'intuito
per far sì che emerga però dobbiamo
riuscire a calmare questo flusso di
pensieri a zittire i rumori di fondo
della psiche attraverso la meditazione
la mente è un ribollire di pensieri
all'inizio sembra difficile riuscire a
controllarli a guidarli ma bastano pochi
esercizi con la pratica così come per
l'allenamento fisico risulterà tutto
molto più semplice può capitare anche
mentre facciamo la doccia o stiamo
guidando in macchina o passeggiamo in un
bosco quando siamo tranquilli e
rilassati ma come si distinguono le vere
intuizioni d'arresto delle idee che
emergono nella nostra mente bisogna fare
attenzione alla qualità di queste idee e
alle sensazioni che proviamo
gioia sicurezza e certezza assoluta
della risposta esatta
oltre ad avermi insegnato l'importanza
di ascoltare me stesso battiato mi ha
insegnato anche l'importanza
dell'evoluzione interiore attraverso lo
sviluppo della sensibilità aprendosi
all'altruismo lui mi diceva evolvendo ti
farai del bene anche agli altri perché
siamo tutti interconnessi ecco io ora
sto lavorando proprio su questo aspetto
sull'urgenza del passaggio dall'io al
noi dobbiamo diventare consapevoli di
essere parti di un tutto meno ripeteva
sempre caro daniele ricordati la via è
solo una capire che siamo un tutt'uno
provare le vertigini dell'infinito per
me è un modo per sentirsi parte
integrante del tutto è come ricevere una
piccola illuminazione che immediatamente
ridimensiona le problematiche della vita
quotidiana
le vertigini dell'infinito si trovano
osservando il cielo stellato almeno per
me e questo è il mio modo dobbiamo
tornare a puntare gli occhi al cielo la
prima cosa da fare è capire che siamo
tutti a bordo di questa gigantesca
astronave che viaggia nello spazio
e già viene un sobbalzo poi dobbiamo
arrivare a percepire la
tridimensionalità la profondità dello
spazio siccome la volta celeste appare
piatta dobbiamo ragionare sulla distanza
delle stelle li possiamo provare questa
vertigine
io ogni volta il commuovo
sento proprio una profonda gratitudine
quasi devozione nei confronti della
bellezza della vita perché mi rendo
veramente conto che siamo tutti
interconnessi
io vi ringrazio perché questa sera mi
avete dato la possibilità di stabilire
un contatto così profondo con ognuno di
voi
ora sto davvero bene grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]